or a Pico rush-hour in Mexico City for
residents here it's simply part of the
daily grind there are some 8 million
vehicles on the city's roads they
release tons of dust particles into the
air most of them from older vehicles
especially buses and trucks the
government wants to take as many as
possible off the roads drivers who have
their old vehicles scrapped are eligible
for government subsidies an incentive to
switch to more environmentally-friendly
models Germany's international
development agency the GI Z is advising
city employees on how to run the program
some 400,000 trucks have already been
destroyed
McKenzie does pour for every truck
that's destroyed as part of the
scrappage program there's a reduction of
20 tons of greenhouse gas emissions per
year that leads to a significant
improvement in Mexico's air quality
quality to Mexico by
even better than trading in your old
vehicle is hopping on a bike instead
these a Coby sees can be ridden for a
small fee
but another solution is taking root to
biologists hey Ronnie Morris works at
Mexico's largest public research
university the UN am he's planted a
garden on the roof of a private school
rooftop gardens like these have become
increasingly popular in Mexico City
Mexico City is overpopulated and there's
nowhere to plant green areas like this
but they're just what the city needs
because the plants produce oxygen and
capture pollutants the biologist has
another concern as well he's determined
only to grow native Mexican plants in
his gardens most of the plants here are
succulent meaning they store moisture in
their fleshy leaves they can also
survive for long periods without water
birds and insects are benefiting from
the rooftop gardens as well this garden
now boasts more than 90 different
species and that number is set to grow
you